you know what i love that you're so
honest about that because that's so
important for people to hear not only
for women to hear it but for men to hear
it because
you know i i've said this before and you
know
it's way [ __ ] harder to be a woman
it's so obvious
the [ __ ] that you guys go through and
then you're having periods and then
giving birth and then all the hormones
and the [ __ ] it's just it's just not
even on the same [ __ ]
level ever then you start to get as
women we say
then you start to get okay after having
your kids and you think everything's
gonna go fine
and then you go into uh menopause and
everything gets [ __ ] how does
menopause start
it depends on the person my mom started
really early so i might be
starting in my 40s somewhere she started
at 39 that's how powerful she was she
was like i'm done and she like set her
body into menopause just by sheer
willpower
but um it really messes with you like i
have so many girlfriends that are a
little bit older than me
and they're going through it right now
and it's like
they're [ __ ] so angry and so stressed
and
so depressed and it's all these emotions
that are going by the postpartum i just
never really understood it i never
because i'm a guy and then um my friend
nate
years ago uh he had a baby and um
his mom terry calls me one day you know
southern woman lover karma she's like
hey mike uh
amy's gone and i said what terry what
uh we lost amy and i go
what what do you mean nate's wife she
owe overdosed on pills to a bottle
single
[ __ ] postpartum and it's such a serious
thing
that was a huge wake-up call where i was
like this woman wasn't suicidal this
woman wasn't
like wanting to take her life this is
postpartum is a real
thing and she and they
i don't know they weren't on top of it
or she was too shy or too reserved
didn't want anybody to know that she was
having these feelings and these
and for whatever reason she took a bite
and then didn't wake up and it was the
most heart and i had to fly to indiana
and i stayed with nate a week and i was
on baby duty at like one
three and five to change the diapers and
i'm like what the f
and just hanging out with him and going
this is just
awful so uh yeah i don't know why i felt
compelled to tell that story
um if you're okay extrapolating on that
i don't know if you want it to be like a
happy or like a
like my is this okay for the podcast
yeah no i mean this is real [ __ ] man
okay so
one of the things about i found about
postpartum is is like in hindsight when
you look back you realize that wasn't
quite normal like i don't even think a
lot of times unless women have read
about it beforehand
and have support they don't really know
that they have it they don't know
they're just
living in it so one of the major things
that women
that i've talked to and myself felt was
when i had my children i had a panic
because i realized i wasn't going to be
alone in my head ever again
there was always going to be a person
there and that freaked me out and not
only was it a person it was a person
that i felt
i didn't deserve to take care of and
there's a lot of women that experience
that
they think if it would be
actually they really think this because
i remember thinking this clearly and i
remember thinking it was loving it would
be easier if i
wasn't around than for me to be
around and [ __ ] them because i was so
terrified
that i was going to mess them up and
they were so perfect
that i thought but it's better that
somebody else that's more calm and that
could do this right would be around than
me
and i just wanted to disappear and
i seem like a completely logical thing
completely logical
like this is a loving choice that i'm
making so i'm not going to put on
what you know what happened to that
woman but they really like it's not out
of a selfishness it's out of the sense
of like i can't
i'm going to hurt you i'm going to wreck
you you're perfect i understand
honestly i wha what you just said
absolutely resonates
it is probably what most parents feel or
mothers
feel to a certain degree i mean
certainly some are meant to be absolute
mothers and want to give birth
the second they can you know and some
don't and some wait and some are act you
know they well i hate to
use the word accidents they're all
miracles little miracles um
but the biggest fear i have in this on
another level of course
throwing it back to me but in a way that
i can understand or make you understand
that i understand you
is that i think part of the reason maybe
i didn't you know i haven't become a
father i always scares me i'm like
well who's going to teach the kids math
i know it sounds funny
who's going to teach the kids science i
i'm going to fail i'm gonna fail this
kid i'm gonna [ __ ] up i'm gonna
i'm gonna ruin this kid's life i can't
do this like it's almost like
it's it's what are you doing yeah of
course you could do this but
you get start imagine and now amplify
that
by actually being a woman who's giving
birth to this child
and so i can't even imagine it's it it
is
uh i absolutely understand what you're
saying that makes perfect sense where
you're like i i can't do this i'm gonna
fail this person so it's easier for me
to go it's the enormity
going full circle if if you can have
somebody in your life that's supporting
you
and with you which is not really usual
in you know like western culture to have
like
the mother and the auntie and this
person that person to kind of go
let's not project into the future let's
just do today yeah like if somebody
just said let's just do today let's not
project into like
what they might do when they get older
or how you're gonna
you